the big lie to use a popular phrase
that america is a vicious awful racist
place and that
our justice system is totally rotten the
whole country is rotten and therefore
the police who are the physical
representation of law and order and our
whole sense of justice in this country
therefore they are all evil this
pervades
the country such that people now feel
that they have the right
to scream and yell at the cops and
interfere in their jobs i was just going
through the jacksonville airport the
other day
this flight just two days ago i was
flying back from jacksonville and
police were arresting some crazy lunatic
who was making a big nuisance of himself
and certainly should have been arrested
and
but he was a black guy now the some of
the cops were black too so it's not like
this was
a white supremacist racially split
no it's there was a black guy being
arrested as he should have been because
he was making a nuisance of himself in
the airport
and what happens a group of people
crowds around and starts filming
everything and starts screaming at the
cops
tells the cops you don't need to hold
him like that what is this what does
this person know
about how the cops need to hold people
to arrest them starts screaming starts
yelling
we got an incident like this on video
just the other day cop
pulls a woman over because she's using
her cell phone while she's driving
and the woman launches a vile
stream of invective at the cop
harass today because i was going under
the speed limit i was going at 38
yes you are ma'am good morning which is
and the speed limit is 40
and i was going 38 so why are you
harassing you are correct i pulled you
over
because you're a murderer yes i started
to record because you can't be it
you can't be on your cell phone while
you're driving when i was recording you
because you said
may i have your driver's license i it's
it's at my
apartment what's your apartment it's at
my home i'm just taking my son to his
do you have do you have your driver's
license if i mistakenly left it at home
do you have a picture of your driver's
license
yes i do may have it and can you call
your supervisor please
i already did he's on his way because
you're a murderer okay
and so you're giving me a cell phone
ticket is that why you're harassing me
not harassment i i am enforcing the laws
i have a right to
and record the police when they're
harassing me by all means
but you can't do it while you're driving
i was i can i wasn't
doesn't texting or none of that do you
have
a picture of me and made me think you
were gonna murder me okay well i'm sorry
you feel that way
well you're that's not just a feeling
you're a murderer
does this woman sound like she's afraid
that she's gonna be murdered
no i don't i don't think she sounds
afraid of any i don't think she even
sounds afraid that she's gonna get a
ticket
because she's playing the race card and
she
knows that this is a lie she knows it's
a lie that the cop is a murderer
because if she really thought the cop
was a murderer she'd be crying and
shaking in her car and she
she wouldn't be screaming at him and and
acting as though everything's going to
go just fine for her as long as she
keeps playing that race card she knows
it's a lie
but it's a lie to her advantage and it's
a lie that's been incentivized all
around the country in the culture
so she's going to keep doing it this is
also a point that
i think must be made you hear a lot
particularly from blm that the cops
target black people right that's
that's one of the main contentions of
blm and
i can i think a lot of the people who
are pushing that idea are just being
dishonest and trying to achieve radical
political ends but
there are i bet people who believe that
because
everyone hates dealing with the cops
everyone i've been pulled over
so many times in my life because on
occasion i've driven a little faster
than the speed limit
okay and sometimes maybe i've rolled
through a stop sign
and on one occasion i actually didn't do
anything wrong the cop was wrong about
the speed limit
on on a road in new york this actually i
know everyone thinks they're always
right but i'll fully admit i've been
wrong
many times that i've been pulled over or
that i've seen the speed limit or
whatever
there was one time i was actually
writing the cop was a big jerk to me and
if i had been steeped in this culture
where i was told the cops were out to
get you the right to murder you because
the color of your skin
i could see a world in which i'd say you
did this to me because of the way i look
you but no cops are just out there
enforcing the law no one likes getting a
ticket and sometimes the cops get it
wrong
not a lot very rarely do the cops get it
wrong but that's what happens
so so far in this in this video you
could chalk this up
to this woman being incredibly stupid
and irresponsible
right she's saying i can i you know i'm
going to try to get out i know i was
using my phone but i'm going to try to
get out of it by saying i was recording
him because i'm afraid he's a murderer
okay
that's okay fine she's stupid she's
irresponsible
but then in the next frame you see that
this woman
knows exactly what she's doing and i'm
perfectly legal and i'm a teacher
so there congratulations you're a
murderer
what's your last name i can't see that
there well here stop shaking
zoom in on that phone because you're
scaring me they're threatening to kill
me and my son can you give me
okay you don't tell you what you keep
smiling you're on camera
you're you're trying to threaten to kill
me i'm smiling you're the one who's
hold that still i can't see that is this
your car yes it is
and you're trying to say i stole my own
car because you're jealous
yeah i don't think so you away from me
right here okay you're jealous
you've got the citation all you need is
your signature
he's only citing you for using your cell
phone while you're driving that's it
there you go bam
sign inside the ribbon for him being a
mexican racist
what is that name yes it's under
citation man
here you go mexican racist you're always
going to be a mexican you'll never be
white you know that right
you'll never be white which is what you
really want to be there you go dear
right
have a good day you want to be white you
want to be what this woman's so awful if
she's a teacher certainly she should be
fired
well michael does that mean you're for
cancer culture yep i'm for canceling her
you bet
because by the way just when some people
throw this at conservatives and they say
well no you support cancer culture
i have never said that people should not
face consequences for what they do
i've simply said that the standards are
wrong the old standards are better
at the traditionals and by the way just
to even take it out of an historical
framework
standards of virtue are good and
standards of vice are bad so yeah the
current cancer culture where you get
cancelled for saying true and good
things
that's bad the old cancer culture where
you got cancelled for being a communist
that's
great i love that we need more of that
so i hope
that that happens i hope that this woman
does not ever teach a student again
if she really is a teacher but you hear
it in her voice
she says oh no i'm just doing this
because you're
you're trying to murder me and my son no
you're she's giddy well she says it she
clearly doesn't realize that she's that
the cop is wearing a body camera
you know the libs pushed for the body
cameras on cops i think because
the very ignorant ones among them the
gullible ones among them believed that
the cops really are just out there
murdering people all the time
the body cameras are going to help the
cops because they're going to show
cynical women like this for what they
are which is trying to get out of a
ticket by making a horrific accusation
and then ironically while she's invoking
racism and racism and racism what does
she do at the end
she says you're a mexican you're a dirty
rotten mexican you're not white
but do you see what's beneath that it's
not enough to just say
see the left they're the real racists
see she's a racist but
what she's doing here is
she is expressing her offense
at the idea that this mexican cop
would not embrace primarily racial
politics inside with her i think she's
black
over the white guy the dig there is not
i hate mexicans the dig there is you're
supposed to be with me
why are you not with me you're we're
supposed to team up
regardless of the truth regardless of
justice we're supposed to team up
against whitey
so why are you taking whitey's side
you'll never be white
you just want to be white right that's
what she's saying at the end of that
that view how vicious how
despicable how totally cynical where
she's saying
forget that obviously she's been lying
the whole time and
sort of gleefully so but then to say
all right you all right i'm going to
tell you what this is really about
you're a mexican you're supposed to be
on my side but you're on the white guy's
side it's wrong and of course the cop
doesn't see it that way the cup says i'm
on the side of justice
and you are violating the law i have
every right to film you yeah ma'am but
you don't
you're harassing me i'm enforcing the
law
that is a new hierarchy that is race
politics
and it is and adm that woman may as well
admit
directly that the notion of white
supremacy is a farce
it's a joke it's a joke to her she just
knows that the lie
of white supremacy might help her get
out of a speeding ticker or a cell phone
ticket rather
that's where we are you're not allowed
to talk about that big lie
and conservatives don't totally get off
the hook here either
because while it is true that the notion
of white supremacy or systemic
anti-black racism or whatever that is a
complete canard it's completely
ridiculous
but concern the reason it works is
because conservatives are a little bit
tone-deaf on the racial issue
and the reason that they're a little bit
tone diff on the racial issue is because
they've actually thrown away
the great insights of conservatism
they've just embraced this kind of
shallow
radical individualism that says hey
every generation the world is born anew
and i don't know you anything and you
don't owe me anything
but that's that's actually not a very
conservative insight the conservative
view of the world
is history does matter tradition does
matter
we owe things to our posterity and to
our
ancestors hey don't go anywhere
because youtube will tell you sometimes
that
you know you'll get notifications for my
show well you know what i call that i
call that a big lie
you need to make sure that you ring the
bell that you like that you subscribe
and then you will have a slightly better
chance of getting notifications when we
get new videos out see you then